madame monsieur bonjour et bienvenue
pour ce deuxième numéro de dimanche en
politique en bourgogne
à huit mois de l'élection présidentielle
il est peu de dire que les candidats se
bousculent à droite comme à gauche est
aujourd'hui bien c'est de la gauche dont
nous allons parler et plus précisément
du parti socialiste avec deux questions
centrales françois hollande peut-il se
représenter ou doit-il se représenter et
le ps est il au bord de l'implosion
alors pour en rediscuter trois élus
socialistes sont sur ce plateau françois
patriat bonjour
non je vaux l'ancien président de la
région et vous êtes toujours aussi
sénateur de la côte d'or
il soutient fait revendre des manuels
macron tout michel neugnot bonjour je
vais le vice président actuel de la
région bourgogne franche comté premier
secrétaire fédéral du ps en côte-d'or et
vous soutenez toujours françois hollande
et puis philippe baumel bonjour député
de saône-et-loire député dit frondeur et
soutiens d'arnaud montebourg
alors on va commencer cette émission si
vous voulez bien par cette une de libé
que vous avez sans doute tous vu cette
lune de libération paru au lendemain du
discours du président la république
salle wagram pépère se réveille à titrer
a osé titrer libération en ajoutant ce
sous titre avec un discours comme on
l'attendait plus le président a fait un
pas de plus vers une candidature
vous les trouvez comment vous c'est une
de libé michel deniau des personnels à
une haie puis à la réalité j'étais
présent selva au g
et c'est vrai que c'est un excellent
discours de françois hollande on a
retrouvé un france olympique nash on l'a
retrouvé leur dire qu'il a dormi pendant
4 ans comme l'un des 100 dans la norme
mais attendez on a retrouvé un françois
hollande pub nash comme il était en
campagne comme il sait l'être en
campagne et partout c'est très bien que
entre un candidat en campagne un
président en exercice
le ton différent parce que les
responsabilités sont différents donc il
a donné toute la mesure de ce qu'il
portait et de ce qu'il va porter à la
finir il est en campagne
il est en train de placer des fondations
de
sa probable campagne voci françois
patriat vous allez lui cette lecture de
ce discours un discours offensif sur
deux sont le discours est excellent la
france est une idée bon la france et
unité les dacquois et la décliner l'idée
avec le talent qui est le sien ce sur
quoi je m'interroge c'est que cette
réunion qui était commanditée par ses
proches de façon à aujourd'hui le mettre
en situation le lancer exprimé à le
lancer et le pressaient de le faire tout
le monde le demandait j'ai bien compris
est-ce que ça a été repris est-ce que ça
a été entendu moi je peux vous dire je
sais que ceux qui votaient gélules
discours je n'ai aucune retombée par
ailleurs aucun retour c'est comme si le
sentiment aujourd'hui que le français
n'avait pas écouté ne vais pas entendu
interrogées les français inédit dans
l'art et bien j'ai pas dis l'audible pad
inaudibles parce que le président a
trouvé des mots forts des mots justes
mais il n'est plus entendue il n'est pas
entendu
voilà on va y revenir vous philippe
maumet libé le dit aussi il a pilonné la
droite ça devrait réjouir ça quand même
bien sûr parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
choses à dire sur ce que sera la droite
demain éventuellement si elle revenait
aux responsabilités mais c'est tout ça
vient un peu tard et je crains de la vie
évidemment de françois patriat parce que
je n'ai pas non plus dans ma
circonscription entendu parler de ce
discours nous on a le sentiment que
c'est un discours qui est fait pour
essayer de se remettre en situation
alors que le président est dans
l'impasse une impasse qui l'a créé lui
même est malheureusement aujourd'hui je
ne sais pas s'il sera en capacité de
véritablement de re rentrer dans une
campagne de présidentiable parce qu'en
vérité il a beaucoup déçu on le sait
tous
alors avec cette rentrée on le sent en
tout cas avec ce discours de wagram mais
il ya eu aussi de nombreuses autres
initiatives de part et d'autre on sent
que la campagne a vraiment en train de
commencer les frondeurs étaient réunis à
la rochelle c'était le week-end dernier
là même où a été annulée l'université du
ps c'était une provocation
c'était une vocation peut être mais
c'était surtout un lien avec l'histoire
du parti socialiste puisque nous étions
dans un lieu où se passer du temps de
françois mitterrand en vérité les
universités d'été et donc on a voulu
aussi faire ce lien là pour montrer que
on avait cet appétit en quelque sorte de
renouer avec un positionnement du parti
socialiste qui était à l'époque beaucoup
plus à gauche henry
donc il y avait une envie de travailler
une envie de travailler sur le fond de
définir en somme projet partagé et de
faire en sorte aussi parce qu'il faut
être sincère qu'un certain nombre de
candidatures s'organisent pour se
rassembler derrière une seule des
candidatures pour les normes par ce
courant ça n'est pas fait pour l'instant
mais on y travaille
vous l'avez vécue comme une provocation
le fait que les frondeurs ce sera nice à
la rochelle à ou ps2 vers les chats mais
ca annuel
les socialistes sont toujours réunies at
il ya des courants les courants se sont
toujours exprimées ont essayé de
débattre entre eux pour avoir une et une
confrontation d'idées et une
confrontation d'idées le premier
secrétaire avait décidé que ce ne serait
pas la recherche que ce serait non on a
vu les risques qu'il y avait à maintenir
cette université j'en profite pour dire
que nous avons des universités et
catéchèse le territoire et la dernière
d'entre elles qui nous permettra de
débattre aussi de ces sujets là entre
socialistes aura lieu à dijon le 20
novembre prochain dimanche juin devant
je crois date de la preuve du premier
tour de primaire de l'adroit donc ce
besoin ce besoin qu'ont les socialistes
et de tout temps les rocardiens se sont
se réunissaient des bons bourgeois se
réunissaient les jospinistes les
hollandais se réunissent c'est une
habitude n'a pas sauté
ça ne m'a pas choqué que un courant du
parti souhaite affiner ses positions
pour participer au débat général du
parti socialiste ce qui sera normal
c'est effectivement il ya plus de débat
d'idées au parti socialiste qui est plus
de confrontations d'idées
parce que le socialisme c'est une idée
fort que mes qui doit s'adapter à la
réalité du moment mais qui ne doit pas
perdre la volonté du débat et la volonté
de la confrontation des idées tout en
restant avec une certaine vigilance de
ne pas abîmer
cet appareil c'est vous obtenez avait ce
qu'il représente
je suis pas sûr que les français et
bourguignons les francs comtois les
français aujourd'hui s'intéressent à nos
petites divisions
terne et veulent savoir ce que vous
voulez mais aujourd'hui il voudrait
savoir comment ce pays va sortir de
l'ornière veut éviter le déclin pour
atteindre le redressement est ce que je
constate à gauche suis de gauche
emmanuel macron b de gauche et de gauche
il constate aujourd'hui c'est que la
gauche est atteinte d'un somnambulisme
collectif déchiré entre ce qu'elle sait
avoir été et c'est qu'elle devrait être
et pour ce faire il ya le totem savez le
totem du remords vous regarde toujours
la gauche de 45 la gauche de 20 la
gauche d'avant et puis il ya le total de
l'ambition qui est aujourd'hui de
trouver de nouveaux compromis qui
retrouve de nouvelles alliances je
considère en particulier que l'alliance
qu'avait fait françois mitterrand
l'union de la gauche de 71 a vécu elle a
vécu il ya une partie de la gauche qui
ne veut plus qui recule qui est la gorge
des conservatismes la gauche archaïque
alors débattent débattre avec eux citent
inutile aujourd'hui il faut trouver un
nouveau compromis
il faut trouver de nouvelles alliances
il faut réunir les gens qui sont pour le
progrès de chaque côté chacun pour
demain leurs savoirs entre man land pas
hollande
je pense qu'ils pensent que le prêt dans
la république aujourd'hui il a une tâche
immense
il assume sur le plan international je
crois avec beaucoup de courage et
détermination
je le plan c'est beaucoup plus difficile
sur le plan interne mais aujourd'hui
n'est pas candidat que je sache
emmanuel macron n'est pas candidat aussi
arnaud montebourg est candidat à la
candidature bien ce pas candidat parce
qu'on est en train de faire le casting
inverse des personnes avant les idées et
avant les projets
on le voit notamment les projets au
loyer casting collège j'ai certes on le
voit chez vous quand même on va pas
s'inscrire aujourd'hui dans la chaîne
alimentaire des candidats c'est quand on
aura vu d'ici deux mois où avant les
primaires moi je ne crois pas qu'elles
auront lieu les primaires je pense sont
des primaires de confort qui ont été là
pour permettre aux changements mal à
avoir du temps à perdre dans cette danse
est de domaine là je crois qu'il faut
d'abord parler du projet des idées voir
si elles rencontrent opinions et après
mais c'est compliqué parce que même chez
les frondeurs il y en a pas un qui a la
même idée du coup il ya quatre candidats
gérard filoche marie noëlle lienemann
benoît hamon arnaud montebourg ça paraît
incompréhensible pour les gens qui vont
il ya une multitude de candidatures
déclarées au sein du parti socialiste
mais précisément les primaires elles ont
été inventées en 2011 exercice 2012 dans
une situation qui était tout à fait
similaire tout simplement parce que
lorsqu'on a un échiquier éclaté c'est
une machine à rassembler des primaires
et c'est pour ça qu'elles sont utiles et
qu'elles sont valides c'est que
précisément elles permettent de choisir
sur lui qui est en capacité de
rassembler le plus largement pour faire
peur non pas un leader naturel et ils
nous ont la chance d'avoir beaucoup
d'hommes et de femmes de qualité et donc
à difficulté c'est de choisir mais on va
pas choisir entre nous on va laisser
choisir l'ensemble de ceux qui sont soit
membre du parti soit autour du parti
socialiste avec d'autres candidats menée
par contre qu'on va jouer cette primaire
de l'intérieur ce qui était ce qui est
véritablement pas très honnête c'est
ceux qui ont été responsables au
gouvernement d'une bonne dans pendant
une bonne partie du quinquennat d'une
politique essentielle celle de
l'économie et de l'industrie est
aujourd'hui qu'ils disent je me lave les
mains des règles du jeu à gauche et je
joue cavalier seul et finalement je vais
être au bout du compte celui qui va
organiser systématiquement s'il continue
comme ça c'est l'échec de son propre
camp moi j'entends ce que dit françois
patriat
il nous dit il nous répète qu emmanuel
macron et de gauche et qu'il le démontre
mais qu'ils soient dans une forme de
loyauté vis-à-vis de son camp ce qui
n'est pas le cas où on va continuer
juste un regard des mots sur les sur les
frondeurs qui tape quand même
particulièrement sur le chef de l'état
quasiment depuis le début du quinquennat
dès le mois d'août 2012 on a entendu des
voix discordantes ça a été assez assez
tôt quand même et du coup ce qui fait
dire à bruno le roux il l'a répété à
l'envi cette semaine on va voir sa
citation sans doute à l'antenne les
frondeurs ne pensent qu'à leur petite
boutique est ce que ça donne pas cette
impression en fait ne vouloir exister
uniquement en tapant sur eux le
gouvernent et je ne sais pas parce qu'il
faut se méfier parfois boutiques et
boutiquiers et 2001
je ne sais pas aujourd'hui que quelle
est la boutique de bruno le roux qu'il
défendra jusqu'au bout nous verrons bien
je veux pas être trop méchant mais je
pense que les frondeurs nous ce vocable
est venue alors que nous ne cherchons
pas nous nous avons essayé d'être
fidèles à ce que nous avons entendu lors
des précédentes campagnes
présidentielles législatives et nous
savons pourquoi nous avons été élus nous
n'avons pas été élus pour accompagner au
cic ur des 40 milliards de cadeaux au
patronat sans conditionnalité nous
n'avons jamais été élu pour ça et nous
avons dit justement que nous étions en
rupture par rapport à ça et ceux qui ont
porté de ceux de telles idées je pense
que d'une certaine façon on trahi le
mandat qu'ils avaient été données donc
on a été en fidélité par rapport à ce
que nous avait dit nos électeurs et on
le sera jusqu'au bout dès 2012
on a tiré la sonnette d'alarmé on n'a
pas posé de motion de censure en 2012
on a tous a été très gratuite et on a
essayé de à chaque carrefour 22 florange
notamment de dire que les choix qu'elle
est être faits n'étaient pas les bons on
ne voudrait pas par exemple que sur
alstom
les mêmes choix se reproduise du coup on
a entendu un discours très négatif
finale mais écoutez soit on est une
majorité godillot
et donc on se plie aux règles finalement
surannée de la vème république soit
abandonnée on est capable comme le
disait michel deniau au sein de notre
majorité de se dire les choses et à un
moment donné de faire en sorte qu'il y
ait une réorientation
on l'a longtemps espéré elle n'est pas
venue l'échec auto rendez-vous
malheureusement à la fin de ce
quinquennat et craque donc alors ça ce
n'est pas ce que pensent les les députés
je peux lesquels les qualifier de
légalistes et les élus légalise comme
comme vous l'êtes
mychèle daniau il ya eu un séminaire ou
si j'ai pas député non non je les ai lu
aussi bien des stages du don clairement
cette semaine il ya eu un séminaire des
députés donc séminaire qui étaient là un
peu pour présenter le bon bilan de
françois hollande
ils veulent faire entendre ce qui a
marché mais chez nous c'est un peu tard
dont vous vous réveillez peut-être un
tout petit peu tard tout à l'heure
monsieur baumel ans ce je pense qu'il ya
eu certainement quelques erreurs de
commises notamment le fait pris dans la
crise qui était plus forte que ce que
l'on pensait la crise internationale
on pensait qu'après la crise des
subprimes ça allait
se terminer la mise en cause de l'europe
qui se montaient des populistes de plus
en plus fort tout un certain nombre
d'éléments qui n'était pas prévu même si
on voyait les prémices de tout ce qui
s'est passé et les horreurs que l'on a
vécu donc le gouvernement était pris à
mon avis dans le quotidien et c'est
souvent quand on est pris dans l'action
la difficulté de au coup par coup chaque
fois qu'il est en mesure de prendre le
temps de l'expliquer beaucoup de choses
ont été faites qui sont positifs dont
nous devons être fiers dont nous sommes
fiers comme à l'est des élections si on
n'est pas fiers de ce que vous n'a fait
je ne défends pas le bilan qui est le
nôtre comme l'un des génies de l'art
département d'ailleurs sa ville il est
bien évidemment vous allez la science
art département qui a été fait
bon et ceci pour dire que on est dans un
contexte qui est mouvant philippe 10
prennent d'alstom problème une faux de
travail qui a été fait par ce
gouvernement que n'a peut-être pas
millas en avant c'est le travail par
filière c'est le travail de l'excellence
c'est le travail
qu'est ce qui va se passer on est quand
même dans une révolution industrielle
industrielle où effectivement des choses
vont disparaître moi j'étais j'étais
directeur comme et 7 dans une entreprise
qui est à venarey les laumes dans cette
entreprise on assemblait du matériel de
manutention
l'entreprise a disparu pourquoi les ya
15 ans son moment les droits de douane
ont été supprimés ou effectivement et
bien l'assemblage s'est fait dans une
seule usine en europe et les unes que
nous n'avez donc chaque fois chaque fois
nous chaque fois que l'on évolution une
évolution
il ya toujours des conséquences sur
l'industrie est ce qu'il faut faire
c'est savoir anticiper cela et dire la
vérité
le moment venu mais entre ce que dit
philippe et françois on voit bien qu'il
ya une nécessité de synthèse si on veut
gagner qui est nécessaire et françois
hollande est roi de la synthèse qu'il ya
eu mais c'est une nécessité au moins que
là
le gouvernement de tel arrivent à se
mettre d'accord et le processus des
primaires est là justement pour devant
le peuple français avec ceux qui veulent
participer
et puis à dire voilà qu'elle allie que
l'on souhaite voir défendre par celui
qui représenterait la gauche avait
brièvement didier guillaume le patron
des sénateurs lui a dit cette semaine il
a été affirmatif à françois hollande
sera candidat il n'a pas utilisé le
conditionnel avec 100 présidentielle
c'est sûr at il ajouté vous vous et vous
êtes sur cette longueur en amont mois
mort je suis persuadé qu'il a envie d'y
aller se persuader qu'il a envie d'y
aller qu'il se met en situation
après ça dépendra de cette décision
personnelle mais je pense que c'est lui
qui est le mieux placé pour rassembler
mais encore faut-il qu'il le décide
qui ça fonctionne à une mère et petite
soit elle mais j'ai connu françois
hollande oui dans des temps anciens où
les idées à 3% ou l'état 3 % dans les
sondages c'est vrai ou d'autres
caracolait et où effectivement
l'histoire a bégayé alors je vois pas le
lien qui bout il vous fait ce qu'il veut
parler d' emmanuel macron non parce que
je voyais le temps de paroles sont
écrites
emmanuel macron a vu partout aussi aulas
il a beau le terrain en ce moment j'ai
même vu invité on verra des images
d'ailleurs à la fête des berlouffes
c'est vous c'est c'est à wattrelos dans
le nord il a mangé des frites là-bas
notera bien il est clair il est
clairement aux campagnes et emmanuel
macron n'est pas en campagne pour la
candidature aujourd'hui que les choses
soient claires jean-yves aux cris d
abord puy du fou je voudrais nos
méthodes et les queens park open il a
dit il a dit loyalement brouiller la
république qui quittait le gouvernement
pour s'occuper de son mouvement
ce qu'il fait en faisant ce qu'il a dit
en allant écouter les français en
faisant le diagnostic de la france et en
formulant un projet et pour ce faire
qu'il s'immerger dans la france c'est
bien c'est la phase diagnostic
alors vous savez tout d'un coup j'ai
entendu un peu mes amis ici s'exprimer
moi je ne nommerais jamais personne et
je ne suis pas là pour avoir des boucs
émissaires ou des procès en déloyauté
parce qu'il y aurait pas ici les les
bons loyaux qui disent qu'il est à
bientôt des gens naky sy beaucoup ou qui
seraient des bons loyaux qui vote des
motions de censure qui tape sur le
gouvernement tous les jours qui est
critique premier ministre
qui s'opposent au chef de l'état ça
c'est les bons et loyaux et les mauvais
noyau c'est ceux qui ont travaillé avec
le chef de l'état qui ont heureusement
heureusement inspiré le cic e et le pack
de responsabilité qui sont aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui les responsables de la
reprise qu'il a dans ce pays et de la
croissance de l'emploi
et puis donc à côté les mauvais loyaux
ceux qui ne critique pas le gouvernement
qui soutiennent le chef de l'état qui
pensent que pour répondre à michel
mignot l'erreur c'est pas éventuellement
kun a dit tout de suite la première
heure et les au début du quinquennat
lorsqu'on explique au chef de l'état que
maintenant l'économie
le monde a changé et que les recettes
les vieilles recettes
on veut nous ressortir aujourd'hui parce
que je vois des candidats qui sont dans
le monde tel qu'il a été avec les
recettes d'avant lors qu emmanuel macron
il est dans le monde tel qu'il sera avec
les recettes de demain avec l'événement
avec une nouvelle majorité
la construire qui rassemble les
progressistes de touba et je crois que
les français ou en anglais 07 du gauche
les recettes alors âgée de lui ce qui
reste dans le coup dans l'autre soit des
partis ou tort les français ne
supportent plus les parties il pense
qu'il ya une droite il ya une gauche il
y aura toujours une droite il y aura une
gauche mais que l'autre soit des petits
des partis avec leur petite recette
leurs petites magouilles leur petite
alliance
ça ne marche plus donc voilà quelqu un
jury qui dit on sort de domaines on va
dire donc ya pas les bons et les mauvais
loyaux et je pense qu'au début de ce
quinquennat
on aurait dû faire en sorte dire que
l'argent public tout le monde savait
qu'il y en avait plus et qu'on n'allait
pas relancer mon pote l'argent public ce
qu'il fallait c'était est d aider ceux
qui créent de l'emploi dans ce pays
libérés les connaît l'enfer et le lycée
l'a fait on l'a fait en 2014 en 2015
sous l'impulsion notamment d'emmanuel
mâcon qui je veux rendre ici cette
détresse détermination il a influencé
on peut lui reprocher aujourd'hui je
comprends mais je pense que ce qu'il a
fait là ça passe ça paraîtra demain
d'ailleurs c'est salué comme tel
aujourd'hui par le monde de l'économie
comme les mesures qui ont permis mais
pas assez et si elle m'a vue elle a
quitté le gouvernement et maniema compte
c'est parce qu'il a dit on fait le
travail à moitié c'est l'art de laquelle
j'ai été désavoué
j'ai été désavoué sur la loi elle
conneries sur certaines parties que moi
je soutenais match désavoué sur la voie
macron d hawaï d'aujourd'hui bien et
bien moi je pense qu'il faut aller plus
loin
la ligne que je définis est une ligne
c'est celle droits de la vie
de l'énergie c'est celle du business
demeure qu'il faut qu'il joue gros
business ça n'est pas être de droite
être la valeur travail est une valeur de
gauche
notre développement et des cantalous un
caca nerveux n'est pas d'accord non je
suis pas d'accord parce que ce que nous
décrit françois patriat n'est en rien un
programme de gauche il le dit lui même
c'est le programme du business c'est le
programme du milieu des affaires c'est
le programme où on va chercher de
l'argent à londres sur la place bouzier
boursières où on vend des classes en
banque et à 7500 euros
ça ne concerne en rien l'électorat zone
de la gauche et ça ne concerne en rien
la définition d'un projet de gauche
donc moi je veux vraiment je pense qu'il
ya une une fausse route qui nous est
proposé aujourd'hui et c'est un est une
forme de dérapage qui consiste à dire
que l'avenir de la gauche serait enfin
reprenant une partie des recettes de la
droite
je pense que c'est catastrophique on
finira avec ce type de démarche
rayés complètement de la carte politique
une bonne partie de la gauche
je pense qu'il ya dans ce pays un
attachement profond un certain nombre
d'idées de gauche je ne dis pas qu'il ne
faut qu'il faut revisiter uniquement les
programmes des années 30 c'est pas le
sujet on sait très bien qu'on est au
21ème siècle et que plusieurs
révolutions industrielles de se sont
passées et que le mouvement social lui
même a changé mais on ne peut pas être
sans arrêt en train de prôner uniquement
la dérégulation sans abandonner se dire
qu'il faut poser un certain nombre de
garde-fous sociaux pour que ce ne soient
pas les plus modestes qui sans arrêt
paye le finalement la note d'un cice que
vous avez rappelé ses 41 milliards
d'euros déversés sur les entreprises moi
je ne suis pas contre le fait qu'on ait
des entreprises pas du tout et
d'ailleurs j'accompagne arnaud
montebourg qui le propose de bien aussi
mais à certaines conditions c'est à dire
que la condition qu'ils étaient celles
de mai des caves et lui même accepté le
medef à l'époque qui était de créer un
million d'emplois il n'a pas créé un
seul
donc c'est la mesure du cic eu
aujourd'hui elle a peut être relancé une
partie d'activités mais en aucun cas n à
relancer l'emploi
je rappelle que sur le bilan du chômage
ce quinquennat c'est finalement un
million de chômeurs de plus dans ce pays
emmanuel macron alors il est d'accord ou
pas avec ça je voudrais répondre sur un
poids parce que notre notre démarche
c'est la bienveillance dire pâle
attaques des autres les français en ont
marre des attaques sur tout le monde
alors quand j'entends à l'instant
critique et nous avons tout mis leurs
pas le parti socialiste touche d'argent
de l'état chaque année 20 millions
d'euros
la république 1 15 million d'euros les
verts 3 millions d'euros le mouvement en
marche qui à ce jour ce dimanche matin à
80 mille adhérents 000 donc pour faire
vivre ce mouvement il faut bien je
trouvais les dons légaux
hors la loi en france la loi en france
autorise chaque français a versé 7500 en
plafond pour un mouvement politique ou
associatif ou culturelles donc on va pas
chercher à londres et celui-ci figure
que londres est une des plus grandes
villes de france aujourd'hui et qui
hélas des français de l'étranger qui
sont décidés à des manuels macron et qui
sont invités à participer à ce mouvement
donc faire croire aujourd'hui là qu'il y
aurait du business de l'argent détourné
des moyens du luxe attendant pour un
mouvement qui ne vit aujourd'hui qui vit
aujourd'hui avec une recette qui
n'excède pas 1 million d'euros
aujourd'hui de dons personnels de
particuliers et pas d'entreprise pour le
faire vivre
je veux pas laisser je pense que je
crois là aussi les français en ont assez
de ces petites attaques venimeuse
il faut il faut cesser ce genre de
plaisanterie quelques secondes avant moi
j'adhère totalement la politique qui a
été menée par contre j'aurai revenir à
ce que françois disais tout à l'heure
c'est une agréable à françois patriat
oui cette logique de développent sur la
stratégie de macron d'emmanuel macron
n'est pas compatible avec nos
institutions
cette année et j'explique nos
institutions elles sont faites de telle
sorte qu'on à la cristallisation à
travers l'élection présidentielle d'un
camp comme un autre et avec la
difficulté ça a fonctionné sans risque
pour la démocratie parce que on était
dans une sorte de bipartisme et
d'exacerber souvent mais c'est la
constitution qu'il le fait nous trouvons
dans un tripartisme qui donne le risque
de l'arrivée de l'extrême droite donc
cette logique d'avoir une majorité
d'idées sur des sujets en allemagne ça
se passe ainsi
on a marqué quand j'ai terminé on allait
chez son amertume
d'arriver au pouvoir on dans le
pas-de-calais ona merkel on a merkel
merkel avec une alliance du spd le spd à
négocier quelque chose d'essentiel sur
sa partie s'appelle son gouvernement
c'est le smic d'un story smic cette
démarche là que l'on peut dans l'idéal à
voir elle n'est pas applicable à mon
avis à mon avis avec la constitution
comme actuellement donc ça voudrait dire
qu'on arrive à un régime parlementaire
qui n'est pas le cas et c'est tout le
débat que l'on peut avoir sur une
modernisation des institutions peut
l'appeler sixième république ont en tout
cas on va voir qui va être nécessaire qu
il va être nécessaire
je crois que c'est ça l'essentiel
mettons que l'on à cette constitution
avait en tout cas pour 2017 on aura
encore cette constitution mariage que
j'ai donc pour l'instant vous est rayé
de la carte tout ce temps vous êtes tous
les sondages le disent besson d'ajouter
encore de cette semaine le disait il n'y
aura pas de la gauche au deuxième tour
vous allez continuer comme ça dans le
cadre des primaires des choses vont se
rassembler on le sait tous on a vécu des
minorités religieuses
on sait que les sondages ont fortement
varié entre le début des primaires et le
point d'arrivée de la présidentielle
donc on est en capacité de se rassembler
mélenchon a dit qu'ils allaient
intensifier ferrand le début de l'année
jean luc mélenchon a dit qu'il n'allait
pas participer aux primaires non plus
emmanuel macron non plus la question
je peux vous répondre là dessus qu'ils
sont jean-luc mélenchon c'est pas la
question évidemment des primaires c'est
la question de savoir s'il pourra se
présenter à la présidentielle
parce qu'à mon avis il n'aura pas le
nombre de signatures nécessaires parce
que cette fois ci le parti communiste ne
me donnera pas ses signatures et que la
déjantée elle est là pour lui on a
toujours eu dans l'histoire de la vème
république la problématique d'une gauche
non gouvernementale qui a pris des
formes différentes mais qui a toujours
existé et qui étaient amenés dans le
choix du deuxième tour hcc christian
paul qui disait ça cette semaine le
suicide collectif n'est pas à notre
agenda on a quand même l'impression que
la gauche dans son ensemble un programme
non le pire n'est jamais sûr vous verrez
beaucoup participent non non non mais la
question qui était celle de cette
émission françois hollande petit a trop
tard ça m'intéresse d'avoir la
trajectoire personnelle aujourd'hui de
françois hollande le permet
difficilement difficilement d'être
candidat pourquoi je donne je donne un
sondage sur les aura pas d
c'est la raison d'âge des sondages
candidate de gauche à lyon deux mille
personnes enquêtées 31% emmanuel macron
mais gérard connaissent assez bien avec
le fort tombés d'accord mais mais lyon
c'est quand même pas innocent pu le
faire ailleurs 31% emmanuel macron
ensuite on a 17
arnaud montebourg est à 13 terra
françois hollande est à 6 alors c'est
bien sûr ta sondages ça ne veut rien
dire c'est lyon mais je veux dire que
dans la trajectoire à lui à l'été gérard
collomb a dit telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui
il sera difficile au président d'être
candidat des jeux finis mais pour
emmanuel macron la décision elle n'est
pas prêt du tout
emmanuel macron il prendra sa décision
plus tard si le mouvement que nous avons
créée a pris s'il a convaincu l'opinion
s'il suscite un élan
s'il n'est pas aussi bien les hors jeu
6-7 6 6-1 que demain si c'est sûr je 6,7
et côté si ce mouvement a pris ce
mouvement a pris et que par rapport à
françois hollande il est en situation
alors je pense qu'il sera candidat il
doit se représenter par vous françois
pendant 30 secondes je pense qu'il ne le
peut pas il ne le peut pas parce que
aujourd'hui tous les sondages le
montrent il est entre autres sondages
nationaux qui donne 10 12 points
d'adhésion de la population vis-à-vis du
prix henri pic surtout ça rend
impossible la démarche sur nouveau c'est
que 7 7% 7 sur 10 des personnes qui ont
voté hollande en 2012 disent ne pas
vouloir voter pour lui anna hazare quoi
t'est jamais tomber aussi bas sac est
difficile à d'animaux ça peut être où il
participera aux primaires françois blanc
moi je pense qu'il sera candidat qu'il
gagnera les primaires et qu'il a une
chance nous négligeons d'emporter
l'élection présidentielle on précise que
les primaires pour vous c'est le 15
décembre pour les candidatures
on a compris qu emmanuel macron
frappeurs partie à dix ans pauline
obligé pas pour l'instant candidats la
grange nature mais je les préviens ce
sera en janvier je pense que cela se
ferait ainsi parce que c'est le seul
match a pesté assemblée merci merci à
tous d'avoir accepté cette invitation
tout de suite place à l'info et bien sûr
dimension politique continue juste après
francis letellier en reçoit aujourd'hui
françois bayrou bon appétit bon dimanche
à tous